donc je prends des balles dans mon gilet
pare-balles et j'en prends deux dans mon
bras dans mon bras gauche
donc ça me fait tomber et je me relève
est en fait quand je me relève je vois
mon mon ami qui lui tombe sur l'avant en
fait et en fait j'ai même pas le temps
de réagir que
en fait là c'est là où mon cerveau un
moment donné il a buggé là il ya une
extension de lumière et en fait je suis
tombé en arrière - dans l'escalier
[Musique]
le boulot d'un commando c'est d'aller
intervenir
sur commande dans un pays dangereux pour
soi libérer des otages comme vous l'avez
dit soit neutraliser les terroristes
soient effectués des renseignements soit
à les combattre des cartels de la drogue
donc cette opération là on est en
afghanistan on est dans un village on se
déplace à pied de nuit avec
nos moyens de vision nocturne
on se fait accrocher plusieurs fois donc
accroché c'est à dire qu'on se fait
tirer dessus plusieurs fois mais
néanmoins on continue notre mission pour
aller jusqu'à notre objectif qui à la
base notre objectif était les deux
otages
on va faire ce qu'on a à faire donc on
va investiguer les bâtiments et les
pièces au fur et à mesure et puis on va
arriver dans cette dernière pièce au
dernier étage du dernier bâtiment où là
malheureusement on a
deux terroristes qui sont terrés là et
donc en l'occurrence ben wallace et il
ya un des terroristes moi je vais lui
tirer dessus mais il va me tirer dessus
en même temps et le deuxième terroriste
bat battre mon camarade qui était à ce
moment là devant moi et puis va partir
de là bas
et qui me va mettre une heure et
quelques pour pouvoir entrer dans la
pièce pour pouvoir neutraliser les
target
alors moi je tombe sur le coup mais je
me relève en fait aussitôt parce que là
il ya l'adrénaline je pense qu'ils qui
rentrent en jeu à ce moment a fait je me
relève aussitôt
et ouais en fait je prendrai donc je
prends des balles dans mon gilet
pare-balles et j'en prends deux dans mon
bras dans mon bras gauche
donc ça me fait tomber et je me relève
est en fait quand je me relève joue à
mon mon ami qui lui tombe sur l'avant en
fait et en fait j'ai même pas le temps
de réagir que
en fait là c'est là où mon cerveau un
moment donné il a buggé là il ya une
extension de lumière et en fait je suis
tombé en arrière - dans l'escalier voilà
donc je suis descendu en roulade deux
étages d'escaliers tiré par mes
camarades parce que pour me sortir
et puis qui aurait l'appui moi quand je
suis arrivé en bas j'étais en fait dans
ma tête j'avais l'impression d'être
aveugle en fait je ne m'étais pas rendu
compte que j'avais été touché
j'ai été touché au bras donc c'est
l'infirmier de mon groupe qui m'a dit
qui s'est aperçu que en fait j'étais
touché au bras et donc on m'a pris en
lima il m'a mis dans un coin on a
commencé
garot morphine point de tout ce qui
toute la procédure de secours qu'on met
en oeuvre
mais pendant ce temps là on se faisait
mon équipe était et est en train de se
faire tirer dessus de riposter pour
essayer aussi de récupérer un bon
camarade qui était tombé et en même
temps se fait encercler à l'extérieur et
on avait la deuxième équipe qui nous
renseigne alala bio qui me disaient
voilà
attention il ya quatre taleb qui
arrivent par l'a13 par là on avait un
drôle on était enseigné aussi par un
drone au dessus
et une fois qu'ils ont été neutralisés
on a on a récupéré
notre frère d'armes et là il a fallu
s'exfiltrer donc là c'est encore
compliqué parce qu'on avait environ 2 km
à 6 filtré à pied avec un mort donc et
avec des gens autour maquis qui s'en
prennent à nous quoi même si le
gouvernement enfin les gens à côté pour
c'est une super mission réussie parce
que forcément on a réussi à les
neutraliser une cinquantaine soixantaine
de talibans
par rapport à l'effectif qu'on était
donc forcément cio ils trouvent ça
exceptionnel mais pour nous c'est ça
reste quand même un échec parce qu'on
perd quelqu'un et et ça malgré tout les
entraînements qu'on peut avoir tout ça
ça reste quand même quelque chose de dur
pour nous
[Musique]
alors pour être commando il faut des
qualités physiques donc qu'ils peuvent
s'exprimer par le biais de marche
commando donc sondé des courses avec sac
armes avec un sac qui peut peser entre
11 et 25 kg sur différentes distances
qui vont de 8 à 30 40 50 km dort pas
beaucoup en l'occurrence en gros ça doit
être deux heures par nuit
si vous arrivez à dormir avec le froid
c'est compliqué quand on est trempés
c'est compliqué non c'est un stage où on
nous laisse pas de répit en fait voilà
sans cesse on est mis à contribution que
ce soit physiquement que mentalement
quand on vous laisse
[Rires]
quand on vous mouiller et qu'on vous
laisse de minuit à 5 heures du matin
deux bouts en plein milieu d'un champ et
qu'on vous dit tout bougeait pas vous
rester comme ça il ya un vent glacial
dehors il fait 3 degrés si vous avez pas
de mental vous abandonner au bout d'une
demi-heure à lorient et la fameuse pub
je sais pas si vous avez déjà entendu
parler d'une tubes en gros c'est donc
c'est ça la forme d'une cure ça fait
environ 7 mètres de profondeur c'est de
l'eau c'est de l'eau qui traîne depuis
des années il ya de tout dedans des
lapins morts les trucs en bas de tableau
l'eau sale voilà mais la particularité
de la cuve
c'est que l'ol est très froide c'est en
gros entre 2° et 7 degrés donc quand
vous rentrez dedans ou prenez un choc
thermique
et quand vous faites le stage commando y
a pas un jour vous allez pas dans la
cuve donc forcément il ya une
appréhension vis à vis de cette cuvée en
fait c'est vraiment le jeu vous parle de
ça parce que c'est vraiment des
quelqu'un disait la cub voilà c'est ça
vrombit tout le monde commençait un peu
à petit côté go pour les salaires on va
donner une fourchette en fait on a un
salaire quand on est en france
donc entre 2005 et 5 euros et un salaire
différent quand on est à l'étranger
entre 5000 et 10000 euros voilà parce
que on a des primes et des primes de
risque et c est quand on est en france
alors soit on essaie d'être en vacances
de profiter de la famille tout ça ou
alors on s'entraîne la majeure partie du
temps on s'entraîne on se prépare on
essaie d'évoluer
on essaye de profiter des retours
d'expérience des différents groupes qui
ont fait différentes missions ce qui a
marché ce qui n'a pas marché et on
essaye de de progresser de manière à
faire évoluer le niveau le niveau du
groupe
dans chaque opération n'a une chanson de
d'y rester et sas ça on le sait ça fait
partie de notre travail et notamment
dans le stage commando c'est tellement
on est poussé à l'extrême
notre corps est poussé à l'extrême de
mental est poussé à l'extrême en fait on
est préparé pour cent ce qu'il faut ce
dire en fait c'est que heureusement
quelque part qu'il ya des gens comme
nous je pense que c'est important c'est
parce que par le biais de nos opérations
chaque opération un but quand on nous
envoie neutraliser ou interpellés
un terroriste important quand on va le
récupérer
c'est peut-être un terroriste qui dans
les semaines à venir tout ça pourrait
faire quelque chose qui pourrait nuire à
la population si bien française
européenne perd important voilà alors
effectivement il ya des très très grosse
valeur mais on n'est pas des héros on
n'est pas meilleurs que les autres c'est
juste qu'à un moment donné on a pris un
nul un autre chemin et en effet pour ça
c'est bon dans les films néron après
nous chez nous comme on dire les héros
il y en a plein les cimetières
donc non on n'est pas des héros en fait